[Musik]
sebastian lege zeigt euch wie mein
klassischen humus mit hilfe von
pflanzenfasern auf die doppelte menge
strecken kann wo die neue lieblings
zurzeit der industrie überall drin
steckt und wie er sie auf der verpackung
finden könnt aber nicht in dieser form
und auch nicht in form der beliebten
bambussprossen aus asia gerichten
wertvoll für die lebensmittelindustrie
ist vielmehr was im harten holz der
pflanze steckt feine bambusfasern denn
die lassen sich vielfältig nutzen
pflanzenfasern der neue beliebte
rohstoff der lebensmittelindustrie was
man da verrücktes mit anstellen kann
das sehen sie jetzt pflanzenfasern sind
der neue trend der lebensmittelindustrie
immer häufiger stecken sie in produkten
in denen wir sie eigentlich gar nicht
vermuten etwa in frischkäse dips oder
tortellini aber warum
schließlich kommen die original
rezepturen dieser gerichte ganz ohne
zusatz von pflanzenfasern aus um den
trick zu entlarven bereitet sebastian
eine orientalische leckerei zu die auch
bei uns immer beliebter wird
kichererbsen vip sogenannter humus
traditionell mit sieben zutaten die
basis erwerbs gute anderthalb kilo nimmt
sebastian für seine große portionen
saison passte sesam ist eine der
teuersten zutaten im humus aber
unentbehrlich für den geschmack ebenso
wie gewürze geschmack bisschen knoblauch
pfeffer
gutes olivenöl je mehr olivenöl desto
cremiger der deckel drauf
jetzt müssen die kichererbsen püriert
und gründlich mit den anderen zutaten
vermengt werden dann ist der humus
fertig
[Musik]
und so schön cremig hmm lecker nur gute
zutaten drin
die wieden zutaten bilden die basis des
humus und bambusfasern die kennt das
originalrezept nicht doch für die
industrie fällt nicht nur der geschmack
sondern auch die menge aus 15 kilo
kichererbsen habe ich zwei kilo
kichererbsen dip sogenannten homos
gemacht der produktentwickler weiß mit
einem einfachen trick geht da noch viel
mehr
jetzt kommen die bambusfasern ins spiel
anders als sebastian kaufen lebensmittel
hersteller die bambusfasern als fertig
zutat chemisch extrahiert gereinigt und
getrocknet ein feines weißes pulver
und jetzt demonstriert sebastian das
potenzial der bambusfasern dazu vermengt
er eine kleine menge mit wasser in
minutenschnelle entsteht eine breiige
masse
klar ist wahnsinn wie das bittet die
bambusfasern sind aufgequollen sie
binden die flüssigkeit wie ein schwamm
so entsteht ein füllstoff der vielfältig
einsetzbar ist
schmeckt total neutral aber darum geht
es ja um 5 stoff zu haben der so neutral
ist wie es geht
ohne geschmack dafür mit extra volumen
die leckere bambusfasern wie die
industrie auch nutzt sebastian diesmal
dem bambus filz stoff
ansonsten nimmt der exakt die gleichen
zutaten wie vorhin
[Musik]
sie sahen passte als prise pfeffer
zu machen
sieben zutaten insgesamt plus bildstock
wahnsinn sieht jetzt schon mehr aus wie
die version die vorher gemacht habe
das ist der ganze topf voll
zur erinnerung die original rezeptur
ergab ein glas humus und wie viel zusatz
menge bringt nun der bambus wasser viel
stoff
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das erste glas ist schon mal vollgas
wenn wir das zweite jetzt zeigt sich der
faser trick sebastian hat jede menge
volumen dazu geschummelt im wesentlichen
wasser doch das fällt kaum auf wahnsinn
doppelt so viel masse dank der
bambusfasern
findige fabrikanten können mit diesem
trick also billig volumen in ihre
produkte pumpen und wir kunden müssen
dann für wasser teuer bezahlen
[Musik]
richtiger ärzten schmeckt genauso alles
da so wie man es kennt sind aber nicht
so viele kichererbsen drin wie man oft
was bei humus funktioniert gilt auch für
andere produkte
in tortellini füllung frischkäse
brotaufstrich und saucen finden sich
ebenfalls oft pflanzenfasern
[Musik]
auch aus tomaten zitronen und kartoffeln
ganzen frage in verschiedenen produkten
klingen natürlich besonders natürlich
und der hersteller suggeriert dem
verbraucher das ist jetzt ein besonders
natürliches lebensmittel es ist aber
hier so dass natürlich dieses nicht
dafür eingesetzt wurde um den mehrwert
zu verbessern oder um unbedingt
zusatzstoffe zu ersparen ist hoch
verarbeitet und es sorgt auch dafür dass
das dass wir mehr volumen im produkt
haben und da sollte sich der verbraucher
immer bewusst sein finden bambusfasern
und co solche pflanzenfasern dienen den
herstellern also vor allem als füllstoff
für volle kassen
das nenne ich mal ein profitables
geschäft was du eine phase alles drauf
hat
in welchen lebensmitteln sind euch schon
pflanzenfasern aufgefallen sagt es uns
in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips